I flew here to Miami to sit down
exclusively with Channing and his newest
Leading Lady Salma Hayek to talk all
about Magic Mike's Last Dance let me
tell you all they share a steamy dance
in this movie that almost went awry I
remember him one rehearsal she nearly
dropped me upside down or a kid hitting
the floor
you can't damage the queen queen the
Queen's Crown didn't hit the ground but
it came this close and then he
reprimanded me oh you did I just said
all you gotta do is just let go of me
and then but she went like a pencil it's
hard to remember what you're supposed to
do when you're upside down the movie set
in London hits theaters February 10th
Salma is a wealthy socialite who teams
up with Channing to get Mike back on
stage you're both parents both have
girls do you think about like do I talk
to them before they see this one day
when they watch this there's no version
of me not like having the conversation
of like yes Dad did didn't just do them
in movies I was an actual stripper so I
mean I'm not gonna like lie probably
already know she probably does know she
was gonna find out anyway I know you
said this is Magic Mike's last dance but
leaving off where it makes me feel like
their story still to be told at some
point he was like oh I'm glad this is
the last one because I don't want to
have to get into this shape
it's a wrap
went crazy
like the cookie monster what was the
pizza monster he was so happy on my face
[Music]